effort has to be incisive in the sense
it should be focused calibrated belief
you make effort and foolish effort isn't
it just labour is not going to get you
somewhere right kind of action the right
timing right place all this is important
isn't it so for all these things to
happen you need perception and
intelligence so that's all you must do
in your life constantly looking for ways
to enhance your perception and your
intelligence rest will anyway happen
this is one thing that unfortunately
humanity is not doing they're trying to
become capable of something just enhance
your perception and intelligence can you
see me right now all of you can you see
me just point out where I am use your
hands and point out can you see me are
you got it wrong you know I am a mystic
you're getting it completely wrong now
this light is falling upon me is
reflecting going through your lenses
inverted image in your retina you know
the whole story right where do you see
me right now within yourself where do
you hear me right now within yourself
where have you seen the whole world
within yourself have you ever
experienced anything outside of yourself
everything that ever happened to you
darkness and light happened within you
pain and pleasure happened within you
joy and misery happened within you have
you ever experienced anything outside of
yourself
no so what I am asking you is what
happens within you who should determine
how it should happen somebody else
definitely you should determine what
should happen within this isn't it so if
you determine what's happening within
this your whole experience of life will
be determined by you nobody else but you
isn't it the events around you may not
be determined by you but how your
experience of life is on this planet is
100% determined by you if you take
charge of this if you leave it loose
just about anybody will determinate
they will not consciously they also like
you by accident you just watched two
amazing clips from Sadhguru who take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]